the first clip a melancholia this is
music of rigor Buckner
you know from Tristan and Isolde and is
not a music made for the film is music
you know he's the film I don't know if
he's the case but inspire but the music
is like a Visconti am that in Venice
with the with a mulatto yet oh we have
this tristan and isolde all this prelude
well we have a movie the Opera is around
four hours in half and but it's a
beautiful beautiful unique moment of the
music history I think because is this
kind of is this kind of harmony that
never never ends never arrived to world
you are expecting for the harmony to go
even when the planet crash is even not a
clear harmony where you feel like okay
we arrived to something it's beautiful
to see that is always giving you this
kind of hope that we will arrive to a
point in the upper of course you have to
wait for four hours in health to arrive
to that point normally we do in concert
a day Prelude and the liver stud that
you go directly to the end and and then
you feel like thank God okay we arrived
to a point and it's very it's full is
full of texture music you know the music
takes you you know it's an inspiration
all of this suspension also the movie is
kind of you know you are floating in
something he'd like to be is like the
chance to be floating in the mind of
somebody this is the feeling
the music talking about the power of
music give to you this feeling the same
happened with them with a Domitian but
also it's beautiful to see that I was
thinking with the Wagner with the
melancholia clip the same happened with
with vertigo with the urban music he's
the same kind of arrival when the guy
see the girl coming and explode but no
in a kind of this a musical thing but in
the harmony that you feel like arrive to
something if not you one more is asking
you for more and that is the thing that
I feel two completely different things
or completely different music to this
American Beauty music it's always like
it's never-ending
it's kind of what is taking us this this
this this thing so it's emotional is
very emotional and it's beautiful
because how we can see is our life you
know and our life is a film and we and
we put the soundtrack that we we like
for our life and this is the thing for
example in concert you arrived with a an
emotional feeling you end with another
one and you have been there for an hour
or for two hours the same happen with a
film and this is the thing you know this
is the kind of unique power that culture
arts have you know this kind of
transformation of a simple moment to a
complete life it's like a century
instant it's like when you kiss somebody
my wife in the case
let's let's hope so if in that case you
know stay forever and it's only a few
seconds is this kind of things that we
have in our hands in life God give to us
the power of music is is unique is we
have to we have to be some thanks for
the life to be
so so this comment will likely get me in
trouble but I'm wondering what it must
be like to be kissed by Gustavo Dudamel
if they kiss just last forever
what what kind of kiss much that I can
give you one but backstage